[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin very
excited to be talking about productizing
new technology all the way from 1995
until today we have dance after joining
us hello hello great to be here
basically should be fun yeah no no this
was gonna be great I'm very very excited
I'm very grateful for finding you on the
interwebs and now being able to talk
about this topic that you've been so
deeply engaged with it's crazy it's what
is it now 15 15 years 20 20 almost 25
years doing this yeah 25 years of
productizing new tech yeah so this was
this started for you and like I wanna
I'm gonna give a quick background on Dan
hmm Dan's background did a BA at UCLA
then did a masters in interaction design
at Carnegie Mellon University he's been
in the industry since 1995 doing
everything from doing like tap as the
new click with gestural interfaces all
the way to IOT and wearables mobile pre
iPhone and stuff and all the way up to
Mayfield robotics with curry the social
robot and now most recently on Twitter's
consumer product team so that's a little
bit of background and we're gonna be
diving into all these different
categories as we go let's talk broadly
first about the human experiment we like
talking about this kind of like yeah big
history take on we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is your current
synthesis on this yeah I mean this is
this is a tough time to be talking about
that it feels like just a lot of things
are unraveling and we're being we're
being handed a world that is slowly
slowly falling apart in a number of
different ways social socially
economically climb environmentally all
these things and so it is it is a hard
time I
to be a human but I just read this
amazing book called the ends of the
earth and it talks about the the five
times that bathe basically earth has
destroyed itself and so the earth will
be fine it's just us that I'm worried
about you know there's gonna be should
be you know we'll just regenerate itself
but man yes some days I worry that that
that this is the end of end of end of
times for us that but then again I you
know you think about you know history in
general and lots of people have thought
that about their time so so maybe I'm
just you know a pessimist what would you
say is the most important code rewrite
the most important code that seems to be
lacking right now is kind of the empathy
code empathy for each other empathy for
the situations that that we're finding
ourselves in there seems to be like a
real breakdown there and and like being
able to very easily dehumanize the other
and I think that's a that's just a
poison and so but well I think it's even
tricking our own brains to think oh you
know that oh it's other people that may
that are gonna suffer from this you know
climate change and stuff like that so I
think it's I think it's just a short
sightedness of human human nature
yeah we're not very good at the like
long-term thinking or thinking outside
of tribes you know the small small
clusters that our brains are wired for
yeah so it's two things it's kind of
taking the mind into this longer-term
deep time maybe perspective and yeah so
taking our are the what we have
programmed with us to think about
nuclear family being our only kin and
extending that out then 50 out to the
global village yeah I mean you know
going into the whole Dunbar number who
were you know we're we're wired to think
about you know 150 people and that's our
clan and that's sort of you know and so
it's harder for us to think you know
city wider or country wide or you know
globally and now all of our problems you
know many of our problems are
there they're not just contained you
know to a small group anymore there and
and they're you know super complex
things like climate change can't be done
at you can start at a local level for
sure but the solutions have got to be
global and that's that's what we're
tripping up we're just not wired for
that so we have to come up with new ways
of doing and maybe this is this is where
the you know the AI can help us solve
these big long-term problems that maybe
they're better suited for than we are
well they're definitely not definitely
better suited for running millions of
permutations and very short periods of
time for sure solution right right right
yeah it's just yeah are those solutions
gonna be palatable to us you know oh you
know the way to get rid of climate
change to get rid of all the humans
that's you know it's those kinds of
situations that yeah we have to now be
careful for yeah so alright let's let's
dive into you know productizing new tech
this has been 25 years like you said
which is crazy you know that's as old as
you know around I am and and yeah
exactly yeah so yeah a lot of the people
I work with it's yeah I mean don't
remember a time when there was no there
was no web there was no commercial
internet and so I thought and that's how
kind of I cut my teeth you know I was
working at a book publisher and they
were like have you ever you know have
you ever heard of this thing called the
web and I was like well yes I have a
browser and they're like okay you're now
running our website and so that was that
was really you know interesting and you
know I I had lived in California and
moved to New York and I was like the
only person who ever moved from
California to New York and got a tech
job you know like it was like one of
those crazy things that at that time but
that actually was kind of the trajectory
my whole career has been like riding
this wave of new technologies that I
have constantly found myself like
especially when I was working in
consulting for a long time was like
people would come to us and be like well
we've got this
what can you do with this and whether
that was you know an Internet of Things
idea or a gestural interface or or you
know a robot it was like okay well what
what can we do with this have we know
what what makes the most sense where is
the limits of that technology how can we
make that technology understandable to
human beings and make it something that
people like want and desire and not just
be like oh I've got this thing now
strapped to me or oh my god you know
I've got this thing in my house that's
you know listening to me and watching me
all the time and feels like you know an
alien's been dropped there so how do you
turn like these new technology into into
products that people love and so that's
that's been my that's been my career and
it's been great it's been a you know
fascinating fascinating run that I that
I hope continues yeah the you take you
taking us back to it's a you know the
days of someone being like you know do
you know what you know World Wide Web
right exactly yeah back to back to those
days and for me you know we're kind of
part of like the always always on we
were Windows not yes that kind of like
all that generation of getting online
Windows 98 right that was kind of our
generation and then now the kids that
are coming into the will have had their
whole lives on on the iPhone they've had
their entire lives within rice the
newest tech and that's this next the
next you know the net kids born today
will likely have the augmented reality
tech the spatial computing tech for sure
which was there you know so it's kind of
it's kind of nuts that this is moving at
like the edge is getting to the the
children like and they're spending their
whole lives with me oh yeah I mean you
know my daughter is 18 and she has spent
her entire life with you know her or
especially her kind of teenage years
with a phone connected to social
networks you know it's it's her
existence has been very
for mine in that you know we would say
things like oh you know don't you want
to be with their friends and she'd hold
up her phone and say I'm with them right
now
you know so that's kind of a fascinating
yeah thing that you know you're always
you're always connected you're always
online you're always part of a
collective in a way and that's that's a
really fascinating thing and yeah and
it's only gonna grow from now when you
know when you know as kind of privacy
decreases and those kinds of things we
get you know much more wired into each
into each other and yeah and yeah and
and her generation is like already there
I know I remember it was so weird to me
when in venmo you could see like who was
paying who and I was like I was like wow
that's you know I feel like we've
crossed some some new barrier privacy or
you you know where we've even a fig who
like for Randy Brendon yeah for all
kinds of stuff and it was like wow this
is a this is a new level you know that
we're great example though of complete
transparency and nobody caring like when
was the last time you actually went into
your public venmo feed and when and
started like observing who's paying who
how much money you really don't care no
so that's the thing right is that
radical transparency is actually
perfectly cool right I mean I mean there
certainly are things that I could see
people using that technology for for not
what you know if the default is public
and I believe it is for that yeah I
could I could see someone making a
mistake and paint you know and being
like why didn't want you know much I was
paying for rent or malevolent actors
yeah exactly so and that's you know I
think then what oh sure yeah okay yes
you had you had four books that you had
authored yeah and the on the four books
these are kinda these kind of have been
following this productizing new tech
edge that we've been talking about I
want you to take us to you know you
started taking us to you know your
your work leading up to basically this
this cool phrase about tap is the new
click aha
gestural interfaces yeah and I heard it
in one of your talks you were giving and
it was really really interesting that
that what was this mm and what time was
this this is like 2008 it was like right
around the time that the iPhone was
coming out right around the time pre I
pre iPad but I'd been working with Nokia
and seeing oh it was like wow these new
new devices are definitely all going to
be touchscreen I was doing a lot of like
kiosks kind of work and and it was like
wow this is this is this generations
chance to create a whole new interaction
design language a whole new way of
interacting with computers in the same
way that the previous generation had
done with the mouse and and the the GUI
at like park you know and an Apple kind
of at that yes you know back in like the
70s and and early 80s but now I'm like
oh 20 years later 90s early 2000s it's
like oh this is our chance to start
coming up with this whole new language
to like work with these new devices and
we did and so that was I think that was
kind of my generations biggest
contribution I think to the world of to
kind of the history of interaction
design was all of this work around
mobile and touch screens yeah and then
you know the next generation like you
were saying it's probably going to be AR
and VR and you know and yeah and and
much more on the side of what I was kind
of calling freeform gestures of gesture
form like yes like gestures in space
versus gestures on uh screen yeah I mean
the the gestures and space problems is a
really hard one yeah and I know that
people are you know there are people out
there working on it right now and it's
you know it is one of those things
that's its nascent and
I love that word yeah I formed three
freeform jesters yeah when I was writing
the gestural interface book I was trying
to figure out like okay what are the you
know what are the two kinds because I
ended up talking about two different
kinds of gestural interfaces one is the
one where you're touching the screen and
the other is yeah we're just moving in
space or just be you know just being
present trigger something or hey I make
a you know I make a swipe gesture in the
air and this happens both of which yeah
you know were had plenty of you know you
you swipe her hand under a toilet tissue
dispenser you know in the bathroom right
now and it gives you a paper towel you
know so there are these things that are
like living in the world they're just
kind of their primitive and they're not
as muggy digitized as what we'll see in
ten years years yeah this freeform
gestures are also very interesting for
for just design and interacting with the
computing with the internet into
Internet in general just it's a very
exciting thing that I think is gonna be
all over the world with you know the
four billion devices that are around now
I think we're gonna go into the four
billion people that will have the
spatial computing freeform gestures and
they'll be able to design and create
much more effectively and learn more
effectively when you can see in 3d what
you know what the kidneys do in the
human body or what a certain electrical
engineering component does in a robot
right things like that yeah I mean
there's there's definitely cell I mean
the trick is how do I mean we're talking
about you know the human the human
factor and you know our bodies aren't
made to do this you know the gestural
stuff is like really tiring I mean when
Tom Cruise was doing it for Minority
Report he was getting tired I that's Tom
Cruise you know he's in good shape you
know much less you know me trying to do
gestures and space and stuff for today
it's it's it's tough but I
there's gonna be times where it's gonna
make perfect sense and we'll be like oh
wow that's so obvious why you know yeah
didn't we do that
you know that's interested about the
about the tiredness and then I think the
next one after that is potentially that
the direct neural connection that brain
computers yeah sure after that which is
reading out the thoughts into the
internet immediately to to think that
you want to make that blue and then it
becomes blue and that you want to make
it a square becomes square you want to
go to the certain Wikipedia article it
goes there right and yeah we're a ways
from that I think but that one's very
exciting but it's really cool you know
you'll be will be in the matrix also be
alive I hope when that happens but yeah
yeah in the matrix so that happened it's
we already are dead
well that's that's true we can yeah we
can debate about whether we're all in
the simulation right now or not no but
uh yeah yeah more quick stuff okay um
the you're you're you were telling us
about this transition it was there were
a lot of people that were using you know
the meat stick bandwidth fingers yeah
yeah yeah meat sticks is the we still
use them it's nice like it's so slow
sometimes in the end up but then you
know the touch screens you were seeing
that that was that was this transition
and then you were teaching me a bit
about you know the emotional connection
being something that's so important
because if you have such a deep
emotional connection to the let's say
the software that you're using that you
will potentially forgive some of the
error micro interactions that you have
with it yeah I mean that's Don Norman
has a whole thing like you know things
that are emotional kind of work better
because you love them and you and you
and it's not that they necessarily work
better but it's exactly that that you'll
forgive them their mistakes or your
overlook it or some of it is just so
delightful to use that you that you just
yet you're like wow this is this is
something that's part of my life it's
part of my identity even that you kind
of take that in and you're like wow you
know my iPhone shows off Who I am you
know this is this is this is part of me
yeah it's part of my identity him
because you know you love it and it's
you know well made and all those kinds
of things so then when I was when I was
trying to figure out what were the
things that made someone had this
emotional attachment that's when I
started thinking about oh well you know
it's all these little small things and
that's how I wrote the microinteractions
book starting to think about like what
you know the things that that you love
about a product aren't necessarily the
big features because you know all phones
can make a phone call all phones can
make can send text messages but it's how
they do it it's there's little moments
that make you love a product that make
you like really have an emotional
attachment to it and that's why I kind
of wrote that book cuz I looked at like
oh what's the smallest thing like the
ringer on your phone like nobody thinks
about that like but Apple did think
about that and you know and had a really
beautiful ringer on it whereas you look
at like the old Nokia phones to turn the
ringer off you had to go to like four
different venues yeah exactly and it was
like you know hey this is something that
you do all the time like maybe bring
that to the surface and and and put it
up right exactly and make a really
pleasing little click sound when you do
it so so let me let me see if I can
tackle this in an interesting light
maybe a lot of what like an interaction
designer would maybe think of is how is
the user going to engage with this
product or service and they maybe apply
like the 80/20 rule and they say that
you know which 20% of the features of
the product or service are they going to
want to use 80% of the time and then
they're gonna want it like you said
bring those up so it's not four clicks
away you know hitting the exact step
yeah but it's a pull down and then you
click it like the flashlight on a phone
something like right something exactly I
mean that's yeah that one of the things
an interaction designer does is yeah
think about like who's using it when how
often and then trying to figure out like
yeah like what do I bring forward what
do i what do I push back who's using
this the most
are there parts of the task that would
be pleasing to highlight or difficult to
do that otherwise we need to that we
should that we should put some
functionality in like there's this great
toaster of the Breville toaster and I
have one at home and if the toast pops
up and you need a little bit more
toasting there's a button that says a
little bit more and you press that the
toast goes down and pops up a little bit
more and that's genius it's a great
piece of interaction design it's like
somebody looked at the process of making
toast and saw people like pop you know
and it popped up now I need to push it
down but I need to stand here doesn't
burn but this is yeah this was like oh
let's take that little pain point and
make it into something really pleasing
boom here it is so yeah so great
designers do that all the time I see
that's the I love that so then that's
that's another thing that we can
hopefully embed into into children when
they're birthed into the world is look
around the world and see the different
services products that we've made and
think about how we interact with them
think about how we can make them better
more humane potentially more it brings
things that we use so much forward
absolutely absolutely I mean that's kind
of one of the first like mind-blowing
things when you first start learning
design is like oh look around you know
everything in this room was designed by
someone intentionally or unintentionally
like except for you know the plants were
you know the plants were not designed
my brother except by except by earth and
natural selection yeah I mean all you
know everything here has been designed
and you start to think well what would
the these are all just a set of choices
that have been solidified into a product
and why would you know and start
thinking like well why would they make
this choice why is this long and not
tall why is why there's three threes not
four
so all those decisions is like okay
somebody made them and whether they make
them intentionally or unintentionally I
mean it could have been you know an
engineer that just at that just made
them because oh the sound quality is
better or it could have been a product
manager who's like oh we only we can
only if we're gonna sell this at this
price point so we can only put two of
these in there so it's just a question
of who makes the decisions and whether
they're made intentionally or not and
then another good one done feedback on
that is that then what's your role in
designing our world so I mean I think
the designers role is as like a broad oh
and for like for people thinking like
when you know when you come even though
your everything in here has been
designed by someone right right there's
an ideas then you know what is your role
in designing our world like forever
everyone or everyone yeah I mean some of
it is yeah I mean what you choose to
support what you choose to buy like you
know what it what that mean you know
what that means like what it means in
your life like so you know are you gonna
buy the three dollar one that's gonna
that's gonna be garbage in in in two
days or you're gonna buy the five dollar
one that's eco-friendly you know there's
there's a lot of trade-offs like should
the three dollar one even exist there's
another good question yeah I mean this
this has been a huge consumerism has
taken its toll on the planet versus
writing in the long term yeah yeah I
mean it is a hard question though I mean
it because we get back to things like
income inequality so yeah these these $3
socks are
terrible they were made in a sweatshop
in you know Thailand or something like
that and you know they're gonna fall
apart but someone really needs those
socks at that price point yes but
there's no any better ways to make socks
at cheaper price points no you sure it's
like biotechnology right and then yeah
so then the question is yeah is it is it
worth or how do we really how do we make
it worth yeah someone's time to do that
how we make it worth exactly how do we
make it worth
Walmart's time or targets time to find
the suppliers and do is and and support
them all those kinds of things teach us
about your work you did Mayfield
robotics for a year
yeah I'm built curry this beautiful
social robot and we have a nice image to
bring up as well as some we're guys
its timing so teach us about what this
is like a social robots what is it one
in every 10 US households will have a
social robot by 2020 that was that was
the prediction I think that they were a
little as witnessed by the the fact that
yeah the robotics industry seems to be
going through some hard times right now
I think they were a little optimistic
about those predictions it's just it's a
very hard time to to have social robots
because because you know honestly they
what they're competing against in your
life are things like pets are things
like small children you know I'm not I'm
not kidding
I mean they are I mean they are they are
great in the very specific situations
things like Ronnie where you bring up a
higher res file of one if you just look
up K you are I yeah it's all right we're
not in budget for that that's right
home have a higher res oh they do okay
crazy right okay cool yeah I mean curry
was animate I mean we tried to make
curry to be basically like a Pixar
character come to life and we had a
Pixar animator that helped us create
kind of the the looks the expressions
the the feelings when the robot would
encounter things or have you know have
an error or see someone likes or what
happens when someone touches its head or
you know those kinds of things and I
mean curry for me was kind of a
culmination of a lot of things because
he not only had kind of gestural
interface things where you could touch
him and you could talk to him so that
had voice UI I mean it's a really I mean
they're sophisticated objects moving not
not you know when you're doing like in
and have things type objects they're
usually fixed in place but robots moved
that's our whole point that's what
that's like one of the definitions of
robot is that they move in 3d space
so you co brought one with you they're
collectors items now they are roughly to
the waistline yeah they're about two
feet tall something like okay and you
said you can touch and interact yeah you
can you could touch you could touch the
head and it looks at you you know you
can say hey curry and it looks for your
face and then it has the capability to
connect to the internet so then you're
you know you're asking a questions right
and then it's engaging with you maybe
giving you answers from the internet at
that time yes so curry was an
interesting thing because we had made
the decision very early on in its in its
product lifecycle that it was not gonna
speak human it was gonna speak robot we
wanted to be more r2d2 not c-3po and so
you couldn't
ask it things like hey is you know what
time is it or the stuff like that stuff
like you would ask Alexa or Google
because we a goggle home because we knew
that hey this is this is this is also
gonna compete with them but you could
you know you could say hey you know
deliver a message or like you know what
you you could ask very simple kind of
questions and it would respond back to
you you know would could even like it
could whistle it could it could hum it
could make little you know beeps and
Boop's kind of thing yeah so but that
was an it was an interesting design
challenge that we kind of put ourselves
into in that we really wanted the
character of the robot to be very robot
II and not not Alexa like and it's also
not say you're mentioning that it's
replacing the dog cat little child
because you're this little social robot
right here on the table that that that
is you know engaging with you knowing
your mood sensing your biometrics
connecting to all of your other
connected devices in your home and and
and just you know helping you learn
helping you stay in a potentially like a
happy say there's so much with social
robots that is still left unpacked I
want to get to a couple oh nice nice Ron
yep there's a couple of them oh yeah
there they go I love it don't play the
clip for too long because we can get
those well Marcus yeah I just put it put
it on shot too so they can see it yeah
there you go
mark so all right so um oh mike beebe
cool he would be he would be fun let's
try and get Mike on the show we'll
follow up we'll follow up on that let's
see if we can get that happen get in
trouble I don't know we did short no
shorten up you can do it enough that was
a great video short enough short enough
it works too can't do for too long
alright so yeah look at how much I mean
it a ton of work goes into these
processes in order to yes I mean this
you know and and I was I was just you
know one person out of you know the 50
that were like making this robot
happened it was a huge group effort to
do it and yeah just just tremendous
amount of work all around heartbreak
that it's crazy with the kid yeah yeah I
mean it was really yeah that was the
thing was that it was it was amazing for
people with kids it was amazing for I
mean while I was kind of joking about it
like we're placing kids and pets it was
great when you had kids and pets because
it could keep an eye on them especially
like you know teens and stuff that
preteens that were kind of in the house
you know that might be there before mom
and dad get home things like that were
things that we were looking that's
interesting for this case yeah okay
teach us about what's happening right
now the last two years you've been doing
work as a senior product staff senior
staff product designers right yeah we're
at Twitter this is the consumer product
team yeah the consumer product team so I
I work on what is what you you know
think of as Twitter of the stuff that
that consumers see and yeah so I was I
was first on a team that we called the
possible futures team and one of one of
our jobs was to look at what Twitter
could be in a couple years so we looked
we use a lot of what we called would
known in the industries kind of design
fiction we used like telling like little
black mirror but positive style stories
yeah in order to think about we call
them blue mirror because the Twitter
Birds blue so we we were thinking about
them as as little stories that we could
that we could tell about what what the
future of Twitter could be like in a
couple years and then from them from
those stories we began to extract actual
product ideas and start to put them kind
of in the in that product pipeline to
suggest them to our product teams and
stuff like that
part of you know going forward like hey
like if we want if we want this to be
the future in a couple years here's some
stuff that we need to start thinking
about now and that's so interesting
again you're you know a lot of your work
has been at this at this cutting edge
and even going past it like you also
indicated like you're you love making
science fiction reality so when you do
do things like these blue mirror you're
kind of like simulating out potential
futures and then you're seeing which one
of those do we want and then you're
turning that into product ideas that
then get developed into the cycle and
then released in a couple years and
that's kind of like the idea right
exactly so yeah so myself
Sean Thompson and Lisa ding my co
co-conspirators on this team yeah we
would kind of think about yeah like he's
like future visions that yeah that and
we knew like some of these were like wow
this is we would actually if it was able
to be done right now we're like wow
we're not that we're not thinking we're
not thinking far enough out like if it
was if it was something that could be
done like that year we're like we're not
thinking hard enough we need that that
we should just you know we should just
put that idea aside because it's too
easy like so yeah so we were actually
thinking of stuff that was that would be
a technical challenge that for
technology that either hasn't been made
yet or just hasn't been implemented like
that yet so is yeah really interesting
and then now you know it's so funny
because like the like the public like so
wants to know what happens in like the
R&D departments of like Google and
Twitter oh yeah like all these major
Apple like Microsoft Amazon like want to
know like what's coming but like at the
same time the companies have to like
protect their like their ID their
ideations kind of like their IP right
and so exactly exactly and even you know
even ideas that we may not go forward
with it's it's always like well this
this might be an interesting idea for us
to acquire someone who's who's working
in this area those kinds of things but
yeah it's definitely you know and you
know with with the way that that Twitter
is we certainly don't want to
to give people you know if we if we were
like oh we're thinking about these
people might be like oh when is that
come you know we don't want to raise
expectations for things that that may
you know that we just don't either have
the time or the resources are just you
know not part of our of our roadmap
where we're headed
I mean and with yet you know like every
like ever made your company that shifts
every year now teach us about like you
know you're you there's there's so many
of these possible futures that you know
that you you've been 25 years now from
95 till now now give us like the next
maybe like you're you know you're five
or 10 year what are we take what are you
envisioning we're bringing down we
talked about that a bit with the
freeform gesticulation yeah yeah yeah we
talked a bit about that with you know
the brain computer interface stuff but
like what do you where do you see us
potentially you know engaging with the
internet and with each other in the next
you know in these next couple of years a
couple I mean so I think with the rise
of machine learning and AI which is
stuff I'm working with now like things
are going to get a lot smarter a lot
faster I see a lot of you know being
able almost I mean the way companies do
now were there buying processing power
they're just gonna buy AI power kind of
off-the-shelf
I think that'll be a really interesting
thing where you'll be able to almost
like at an app store you'll be like well
I need this I need this I need this
level this kind of intelligence and this
kind of algorithm to go there put this
all together for me and that's what's
gonna power my app like an hey I'm shop
like basically like an A
algorithm shop you know where you can
you can buy it all from you know been
Gert CIL's kind of working on that yep
decentralized the artificial general
intelligence yeah I mean it's it's it's
it's an idea that's definitely coming
you know that I know yeah people that
are like thinking about it working on
and I'm sure you know your Amazon's or
Google's you know people like people
that are already control the cloud are
really thinking about it
so there's that on the kind of robotics
front the the manipulation of of objects
is gonna get much better in the next ten
years so you will be able to have
robotics that have a lot that can do a
lot more that aren't that cannot be
social but can also be much more
functional that can you know that was
that was our biggest complaint oh can
the robot bring me a beer and it's like
well bringing a beer is a is a really
hard cognitive tasks like centered yeah
like well I mean think about like if I
say like oh that's you know can you get
me a cup of coffee like hey you have to
know what coffee is be you have to know
where it would be so you see you have to
like go to the fair get it yeah and then
you have to have that yeah the you know
the Dexter need to pick it up and do
that you know through actions yeah yeah
yeah there's there's a famous like
saying like that like yeah when when
robots can do what seven year olds can
where they have the same amount of
intelligence in the same amount of like
dexterity and strength like that's the
big game changer yeah robotics and
that's I you know that's not that far
that's not that far away at all so I
think it's a 5-10 years I think that's a
5-10 year you know yeah in 10 years if
the robots that are asking yeah give you
know please assist me with this task or
that task in though in the plate in the
house that's pretty pretty amazing
pretty yeah yeah so I think I think
those two those two things I think a lot
of our shop a lot of much more
contextual computing I think is gonna be
big like just having a lot more aware
of where you are what you're doing how
you're feeling and adjusting based on
that I think that's a huge that's a
that's a huge upcoming thing it's it's a
lot of processing power it's a lot of
you know turning over a personal yeah
data you know that'd be very exciting to
maybe have the lights dim for meditation
music to come on the scent of lavender
to come in sugar to relax like that
stuff is fascinating to me even yeah I
mean even just but yeah super basic
stuff hey I'm in bed you know turn off
my put a Do Not Disturb on my device oh
my oh my oh my Apple watch you know this
well I'm here I mean you have to be
careful about not you know overstepping
your bounds cuz it'll be weird if like
everything is super tailored but I mean
but there are definitely things where
I'm like hey maybe you know you know
maybe turn off there I'm super stressed
me you know all down my notifications
yeah I don't need to know every single
thing totally you know those kinds of
things I think are yeah really
fascinating it's yes so many five okay
can you stay longer than 630 cuz I could
go for another hour with you let's do
the two quick questions okay you were
hinting at this earlier which made us
really excited but this is simulation so
we must ask you uh-huh are we in a
simulation i I think that there is there
is a chance we could be I don't really
have any I don't really have any good
reasoning for that but I you know there
are definitely things we sometimes feel
like wow we've we've moved into a
different timeline or something has
shifted you know there's these kind of
Black Swan events that feel like that
feel like there's invisible hand moving
stuff which you know may just be my
human brain
trying to make sense of of an
unpredictable unplanned chaotic world or
it could be hey we're enough we're in a
simulation so I don't know well I I
think the jury's out I think you know I
think there's been some interesting
speculation about it so i i'm i'm
generally AG agnostic in terms of you
know supernatural beings and yeah
simulations are yeah
godlike beings you know playing dice
with us so for being around you know 25
years and seeing what has really
happened with our almost now it's
getting to indistinguishable connection
to the technological digital realm now
it's just becoming more and more like a
possible that we're awakening to that
possibility more and more because of the
just a degree of tech yeah i mean you
know once you realize how easy it is for
your senses to be manipulated in all
kinds of ways it's not it's not
unfathomable that that we are in some
kind of simulation already happening
algorithmically with the technologies we
use yeah and hope for sure we rewrite
the social code so to make the the
algorithmic manipulation mean be more
towards altruism and and kin the global
village as can you know that that would
be that would be great
for sure yeah i mean if we can if we can
somehow you know tilt all of our
technology towards a more human humane
future for everyone where everyone's
treated with dignity everyone's treated
with respect
figure out ways to do that yeah that's
that's the goal yes yes now last
question is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
Fuji's I would I would think it would be
something like a forest that that's what
that's what springs to mind it's a
complex ecosystem lots of lots of things
living in it lots of things at at
different sizes and shapes and and
things that that are created and and and
go away instantly like little flies and
things that last hundreds of years like
trees and and how they're all
interconnected I think is just an
amazing beautiful set of set of things I
think that that is you know that's hard
to replicate and and just an amazing
creation that that you know when I'm
walking in the forest or or even just
looking at trees you know in the park
across the street from me you know which
is its own little kind of mini mini
forest it's like wow this is you know
this is amazing this is something that I
couldn't have come up you know that that
you it would be hard for a human being
to have come up with this and but it's
amazing that that we get to share the
planet with these things yes yeah so
that's my beautiful thing off the top my
head loved it then this has been a fun
at break I'm super enlightened yeah yeah
sure thanks for having me thanks
teaching us yeah this is very mining
lots of lots of new ways of thinking
around productizing new tech and what
it's been like where it is now we're
going it's very exciting stuff thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
greatly appreciate it we would love for
you to check out the links in the bio
below
that's Oh Danny Boy comm and also Oh
Danny Boy on Twitter check that out
check that out and he'd shout out to Ron
Vargas thank you for producing and
directing we love you very much and guys
we'll have more conversations to talk to
more people about what it's what it's
like our current state with future tech
our future future how do we make it more
humane etc
and support artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in you know all of our
links are below go and check those out
support us you believe in us we would
love love love to continue growing and
impacting more people around the world
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you and we will
see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]